un avertissement de cartes ra quo mais
ne touchez pas au total robichaud à
carter prudence et à commenee respecter
les règles diplomate france dix mille
francs pour un enfant c'est l'une des
six mesures prises en faveur de la
famille monsieur bonsoir la tension
monte ce soit en iran c'est une
expression qui a beaucoup servi mais qui
est je crois le fidèle reflet d'une
situation que nous avons tenté de vous
expliquer le plus clairement possible
hier soir à l'aide de cartes de
documents et de témoignages ce soir les
événements semblent hélas nous donner
raison
les événements c'est à dire d'abord cet
avertissement solennel du président
carter il ya deux heures à peine s'il
survient quoi que ce soit aux otages
américains de téhéran dit le président
américain à l'ayatollah khomeini des
conséquences extrêmement graves en
découleraient c'est une mise en garde
qui prouve bien la détermination d'un
exécutif américain très largement
soutenu par son opinion publique leur
sigle pour les états unis que le premier
décès survenaient quoi que ce soit otage
téhéran des conséquences extrêmement
graves en découlerait je suis très
phrase exacte c'est que le président
carter vient de prononcer après une
réunion de deux heures avec tout ce
qu'on faisait de même
il recevra les chefs d'état major des
trois armes à camp david a lieu les
faits du 5 juillet fête nationale et
religieuse
l'américain reste préoccupé et le
président américain sait ce qui est bon
de rappeler qu'il maintenait ses
positions c'est à dire l'hypothèse d'une
intervention militaire
la vie des otages sert en effet menacé
oui de washington toujours on apprenait
que le chan quitterait les états unis
que lorsque son traitement dans un
hôpital new yorkais serait terminée
c'est à dire dans dix ou quinze jours et
non pas plutôt comme l'annoncé hier un
sénateur ahmed
pourquoi ces paroles très dures dans la
bouche de jimmy carter et bien parce que
les esprits sont très échauffés à teyran
vous allez vous même en juger grâce à
notre envoyé spécial philippe roche
la prière du vendredi à l'université de
téhéran était placé aujourd'hui sous le
signe de la victoire de tram dans le
monde et de la lutte anti américaine
la présence à la tribune devant famile
bertone du nouvel homme fort du régime
iranien
monsieur banny table il est approuvé que
des religieux et le conseil de la
révolution travaillent main dans la main
et monsieur bani sadr annoncé que l'iran
ne paiera pas des dettes aux états unis
car on ne rembourse pas à des pillards
l'ayatollah montazeri qui depuis le
début de la crise avec les états unis
fait le prône du vendredi un fusil à la
main s'est fait l'écho des déclarations
enflammées de l'ayatollah khomeini de la
guerre entre l'islam et les païens et de
l'appel au noir des etats-unis pour
qu'il te réveilles cb l'équité de la
dague de l'ambassade américaine au bac
10 ans et pour justifier la ville en
état d' alerte des forces iraniennes
il a déclaré lee carter adac nous nous
battrons c'est le mois de moharram le
mois du tacul
elle est un peu ce qu'elle dit et sa
manière baptiste le président carter
tout à l'heure et c'est sans doute ce
qui a motivé les propos du soviétique
gromyko il y à une heure à bonn fait
preuve de retenue at-il demandé aux deux
parties
l'américaine et l'iranienne et monsieur
gromyko d'ajouter qu'il était pour le
respect des conventions internationales
et de l'immunité diplomatique ce qui
était une manière de condamner
implicitement l'attaqué de l'ambassade
américaine à taire en tout cas voilà
trois déclarations qui je crois justifie
bien le thème de notre question de temps
lundi soir la guerre est elle une
solution des problèmes du pétrole de la
prolifération nucléaire des rapports est
ouest et de la faim dans le monde
nous interrogerons l'a dit donc après
journal de très nombreuses personnalités
à paris à rome à londres à washington et
à los angeles
quant aux événements de la mecque il
sent prête achevé une poignée
d'irréductibles n'a toujours pas été
neutralisé dans 2 17 minerais minarets
pardon de la mosquée les événements ont
été beaucoup plus sanglant qu'on ne le
disait dans un premier temps puisque
certains témoins parlent de 200 morts
aussi bien chez les assaillants que chez
les fidèles et les gardes sao dia alors
tout ceci nous a poussés à interroger un
spécialiste de l'islam s'il en est le
recteur de la mosquée de paris qui nous
demandent d'abord d'éviter tout jugement
a priori jugé pas de nos problèmes
musulmans suivant une optique européenne
les européens sont
d'autant plus ignorants de nos réalités
qui nous observent de l'extérieur il ne
voit pas comme au les transformations
qui sut le tulle tous les plans de la
vie son père chaque jour l'essentiel
c'est que l'islam ne peut pas rester
figé il y avait su si vous voulez une
période de convalescence après la
décolonisation et l'islam veut d'abord
se ressaisir et choisir son orientation
doit-il s'orienter vers le mans de
capitalisme devait s'étaler l'europe
occidentale et la mairie avec ce peu ce
qu'il est ce qu'elle représente
sur le plan technique scientifique et
surtout sur le plan de l'organisation
sociale et colonies ou doit-il plutôt se
pencher du côté basculer vers le
socialisme
ce que je retiens c'est que est ce que
vous avez dit d'ailleurs au début c'est
que l'islam n'entend plus elle rester
dans le concert des nations
comme une puissance passive et pour
pouvoir pour pouvoir occuper une place
digne de ses proches morale et
matérielle et intellectuelle car
n'oubliez pas que le playlipse de
physique
le prix nobel de physique a été décerné
à un musulman un pakistanais par
conséquent la laine telligent ans de
cette communauté n'a pas été atrophié
par la période coloniale
dans cette affaire les palestiniens de
leur côté se sont un petit peu en
position de force et américains leur ont
demandé une médiation non officielle
dans les événements d'iran ils ne sont
pas contre mais demande en retour à
l'occident de faire un geste à leur
égard et pour eux faire un geste c'est
d'abord examiner d'un oeil plus
favorable
les nouvelles donnes de la situation en
cisjordanie après la démission de la
quasi totalité des maires palestiniens
oui
ouais
autour du palais de justice de vie
rurale amis partisans et adversaires du
maire de naples où se sont lancés les
pires injures les accusations du bras la
police a dû jouer à la fois de la
fermeté et de la diplomatie pour éviter
des affrontements alors que la cour
suprême tenter de répondre à la question
faut-il ou non expulsé le maire monsieur
chaque cas après quatre heures d'une
bataille de procédure les magistrats
n'ont pas tranché
monsieur chaque cas devra comparaître
devant la justice militaire avant d'être
entendu deux niveaux par la cour suprême
israélienne
en attendant monsieur chaque a dû
retourner en prison où il poursuit une
grève de la faim entamée il ya six jours
son épouse venue à jérusalem pour le
procès n'a pas pu le convaincre
d'arrêter une dizaine de maires les plus
en vue du territoire notamment ceux de
ramallah de bethléem de gaza ont assisté
au procès et semblait très préoccupés à
leur sortie du palais de justice
raymond d'atari la militante et écrivain
palestinienne traduisait le sentiment
général de pessimisme après l'audience
il faut une intervention mondial des
pensions aussi des dizaines yapo kouassi
toujours pas ce dont je veux fabrication
et aidant je veux pas me présenter en
cisjordanie c'était une nouvelle journée
ville morte avec la reprise de la grève
générale écoles et magasins ont de
nouveau fermé dans toutes les villes à
commencer bien sûr par naplouse où
patrouillent et des soldats israéliens
c'est un peu la journée les lieux pour
tout le monde
après l'audience devant la cour suprême
israélienne les militaires partisans de
la manière forte n'ont pas obtenu
l'exclusion du maire de naplouse les
arabes de cisjordanie espérait une
libération immédiate qui n'est pas venu
les juges de la cour suprême n'ont pas
réussi à désamorcer la bombe xhaka dans
quelques jours ils devront de nouveau
assumer la responsabilité d'une
éventuelle expulsion qui s'il était
prononcée pourrait mettre le feu aux
poudres à travers toute la cisjordanie
un mot encore sur cette région du monde
avant d'en venir aux affaires françaises
les pays-bas conseillent à leurs
ressortissants en iran de quitter le
pays maintenant donc les nouvelles
politiques économiques et sociales avec
tout d'abord le débat sur la politique
familiale du gouvernement qui s'est
achevé cette nuit résultats concrets
pour les familles nombreuses 2 à 3
milliards supplémentaires dans les 18
mois à venir pour l'accroissement de
différentes allocations que nous l'état
jean michel mercurol si les mesures en
faveur des familles nombreuses ont voté
la session de printemps
voici ce dont bénéficieront fin 1980 les
familles de trois enfants et plus
allocation naissance de dix mille francs
dès le troisième enfant plus une
allocation postnatale unique de 8000 120
francs versée en une seule fois
congé maternité porté de quatre à six
mois dès la troisième naissance priorité
absolue dans les six mois pour un
logement plus spacieux notamment dans
les hlm bénéfice d'un prêt à 100% en cas
d'accession à la propriété prestations
familiales maintenu aux apprentis au
delà de 18 ans cela pendant deux ans
maintien des réductions sncf aux parents
et aux ternes
les enfants de moins de 18 ans quel que
soit l'âge des venez augmentation
garantie du pouvoir d'achat des
allocations familiales de 3% au lieu de
un et demi pour cent enfin droit à la
retraite et affiliation gratuite pour
les mères qui bénéficient du complément
familial ceci pour ne pas pénaliser
celles qui choisissent de se consacrer à
plein temps à leurs enfants
je me déçus par les mesures des 20m
pelletier car il y à l'éparpillement des
mesures et que si certains ont pu parler
de rustines c'est-à-dire pour boucher
certains trous et une pension que
l'ensemble de ces mesures sont trop
limitées et ne ne met pas en place une
politique familiale globale et surtout
une loi cadre de la famille tel que nous
l'avions demandée est proposé est
d'autant plus que nous notons que lance
une partie de ces mesures sont des
mesures à caractère trop démographique
trop nataliste que nous regrettons que
l'ensemble des familles pas été pris en
compte dans quoi concrètement ces
mesures sont jugées par voix suffisantes
et bien par exemple l'allongement du
congé de maternité qui est très valable
en soit pour les femmes qui auront un
troisième enfant
on peut regretter qu'elles ne soient pas
prévus pour celles qui auront un premier
et un deuxième puisque
là ce moment là le congé de maternité
restera à quatre mois en ce qui concerne
la retraite de la mère de famille qui
bénéficient du complément familial
il est certain que c'est une mesure que
nous avons demandé depuis longtemps mais
qu'elle est très limité également
puisque cette retraite existait déjà
pour les mères de quatre enfants il le
touche donc maintenant elle ne sait pas
quoi à l'allongé si vous voulez qu'on
mère de trois enfants actuellement ces
parties du statut social de la mère de
famille nous demandons depuis longtemps
mais ce n'est pas suffisant car en ce
qui concerne le logement les mesures
proposées sont intéressantes mais elles
seront forcément limitées en ce sens que
bien entendu il y aura une priorité pour
les ménages qui ont plus de trois
enfants mais où trouveront-ils des
logements trouveront-ils est
suffisamment grand
d'ailleurs de nombreux députés ont fait
part de leur déception non pas devant
les mesures financières adoptées qui
sont substantielles mais plutôt à
l'égard de l'absence de définition d'une
véritable politique globale de la
famille
réponse du ministre concerné monique
pelletier nous avons un système qui est
un système équilibré
les mesures ne sont pas prises au hasard
ce ne sont pas des actions comme cela
qu'ils viennent s'ajouter les unes aux
autres
le gouvernement s'est donné trois
objectifs depuis plusieurs années aider
les familles qui en ont le plus besoin
c'est à dire celles qui ont les revenus
modestes et il me semble que c'est
justice aider les familles nombreuses
parce que il est vrai elles connaissent
des difficultés de vie parce qu'elles
ont beaucoup d'enfants
et puis mettre au point progressivement
mais nous sommes sur la bonne voie ce
qu'on appelle le statut de la mer et
famille c'est à dire que la mère de
famille soit reconnu en tant que tel et
elles le demandent elles ont raison et
bien les mesures qui ont été annoncées
hier s'inscrivent toutes dans ces trois
axes c'est une politique globale
puisqu'elle concerne non seulement les
prestations mais aussi le logement mais
les transports mais tout l'ensemble de
ces actions
qu'attendent les familles qui ajouterait
une loi cadre sinon une discussion très
longue
très difficile et probablement une
action qui serait plus figé les conflits
du moment d'abord alstom une
confirmation le travail reprendra bien à
belfort lundi au terme de deux mois de
grève ainsi en ont décidé les salariés
ce matin du côté des contrôleurs aériens
en revanche de rêve encore plus dur les
périodes d'arrêt de décollage à roissy
par exemple seront plus longues que
prévu demain et dimanche
enfin le congrès de la cftc s'est ouvert
ce matin à strasbourg au coeur des
débats le lourd dossier du chômage
jean bernard sauvé la générale de la
centrale chrétienne sera notre invité de
l'ain et puis les premiers résultats
d'une enquête qui devrait intéresser les
congressistes de strasbourg et d'une
manière générale tous les salariés c'est
une enquête du cercle centre d'étude des
revenus et des coûts elle concerne les
petits salaires ceux les moins de 2000
francs qui représente un quart des
travailleurs de l'industrie et du
commerce
ce groupe comprend beaucoup plus de
jeunes que l'ensemble des salariés 60 %
un peu plus de femmes 52% un peu plus
d'étrangers 9%
la plupart de ces petits salariés sont
mariés ou vivent dans leur famille et
dans un cas sur quatre ils sont chefs du
ménage leur formation n'est pas
tellement en dessous de la moyenne elle
est moins poussée que celle des autres
salariés pour la formation générale mais
tout aussi bonnes sur le plan
professionnel 36% ont peint ces apps et
19% le brevet ou le bac leur travail
deux tiers sont ouvriers os ou manoeuvre
un tiers employés surtout les femmes ou
personnel de service s'ils gagnent un
salaire faible ce n'est pas qu'ils
travaillent moins que les autres 90 %
travaillent 40 heures ou plus ils ne
peuvent pas d'ailleurs pour arrondir
leurs salaires compter sur des primes ou
des avantages en nature près des deux
tiers n'ont pas ces petits salariés se
trouvent surtout dans de petites
entreprises et particulièrement dans
certaines branches celles qui emploient
beaucoup de femmes le textile
l'habillement l'industrie
agroalimentaire les cuirs et peaux ou
bien alors dans le bâtiment et le
commerce où vivent ces petits salariés
surtout dans l'ouest et le sud ouest
dans la région parisienne ils sont assez
peu nombreux mais
alors ce sont surtout des femmes et des
immigrés un plan pluriannuel pour
l'élevage voilà ce que vient d'annoncer
ce soir raymond barre qui avait reçue ce
matin tous les dirigeants des milieux
agricoles réunis pour leur conférence
annuelle
très prochainement donc dans les cinq
mois à venir un plan de cinq ans pour
l'élevage bovin et ovin reste aussi le
problème du lait et du conte tensions
entre les producteurs le gouvernement et
la communauté européenne
depuis deux ans déjà les agriculteurs
européens versent 0,5 pour cent du prix
de vente de leur lait dans une caisse
commune c'est la taxe de
coresponsabilité laitière cet argent
sert à stocker les excédents de lait à
trouver de nouveaux débouchés pour les
produits laitiers ou encore comme ici à
favoriser la consommation de lait en le
distribuant dans les écoles or cette
taxe risque d'être multipliée par trois
et de passer à 1,5 pour cent pourquoi
parce que les agriculteurs européens ont
produit dans leur ensemble
trop de lait cette année et si l'année
prochaine
certaines laiteries augmente encore leur
production la commission de bruxelles
propose déjà une surtaxe de 3% aux
producteurs livrant le relais à ces
laiteries autrement dit dans ce cas
extrêmes un agriculteur français moyen
qui possède douze vaches et livre
quarante mille litres de lait tous les
ans à sa coopérative verrait son revenu
ou ça paye annuelle diminuer de près de
2000 francs pour le dossier d excellent
anglais nous estimons qu'il faut
responsabiliser les entreprises et qu'il
faut donc que ces espèces de
pénalisation tiennent compte de la
responsabilité des entreprises et des
producteurs
à propos de la conférence annuelle hier
encore elle s'annonce et en duo parliez
même de la possibilité de claquer la
porte aujourd'hui
apparemment ce n'est pas le cas
autrement dit vous êtes satisfait pour
ma part j'ai toujours dit que je n'étais
pas d'accord pour claquer la porte
nous sommes partisans du dialogue ce que
je veux dire c'est que si à sa blonde de
points de convergence sont apparus sur
les orientations à moyen et long terme
il apparaît quand même un certain nombre
de zones d'eau malgré des ouvertures et
notamment sur le dossier des
orientations et les perspectives en ce
qui concerne la réalisation dsm où la
possibilité d'utiliser un certain nombre
de crédits
ils sont actuellement prévues pour
l'utilisation du beurre et la
consommation hubert peuvent nous
permettre si vous voulez d'espérer que à
partir de ce qu'a demandé le premier
ministre c'est à dire que d'ici à la fin
avril un plan pour l'élevage soit
établie nous avons un certain nombre de
perspectives autrement dit si ou lé hier
nous avions un peu l'impression que le
feu est au rouge
nous avons ce soir l'impression qu'il
est encore alors qu'il était maintenant
clignotants orange
espérons qu'il deviendra très rapidement
ouvert parce que nous avons insisté sur
l'importance que représente pour un
salon de producteurs la situation
actuelle de l'élevage la politique en
quelques télégrammes maintenant tout
d'abord les suite de la démission
d'henri fiszbin du comité central du
parti communiste
l'ancien député de paris demandent que
l'humanité publie sa lettre de démission
donc ses raisons mais l'organe du pc a
refusé en estimant que tout avait été
dit sur cette affaire du côté du ps
laurent fabius a réaffirmé aujourd'hui
que le rapprochement socialistes
gaullistes relevait de la fabulation est
que plus que jamais le véritable
adversaire était je cite le pouvoir
réactionnaire incarné par le président
de l'as de pique
enfin ce propos de michel pinton dans
l'hebdomadaire l'économie aujourd'hui
les relations entre l'udf et le rpr ne
sont pas satisfaisantes le rpr n'a pas
vraiment changé dans son sourd désir de
domination
et puis le conseil du chef de l'état aux
préfets à qui il rendait visite
aujourd'hui il les a exhortés être plus
sensible aux préoccupations des français
par esprit de justice car at il dit il
n'y a pas de liberté et de sécurité sans
visite en est plus ou dans nos villes ou
dans nos chefs lieux d'arrondissement
des représentants de l'état s'enfermait
dans le cercle des notables et je vous
invite mesdames et messieurs à vous
porter au devant des plus démunis les
chômeurs les jeunes les immigrés les
salariés des banlieues où les
agriculteurs des montagnes en voie de
dépeuplement
il faut que toutes ces catégories et le
sentiment que l'accès de des
représentants de l'heure
de l'état leur est largement ouvert et
qu'ils trouveront quelqu'un près les
accueillir près les entendre très
naturellement à prendre des décisions
qui soient conformes à notre législation
et à notre réglementation mais qui
tiennent compte de certaines de leurs
aspirations
le directeur et deux nouveaux médecins
de la clinique la pergola vont passer la
nuit en prison la pergola c'est vous le
savez cette critique cette clinique où
sont pratiquées des avortements plus
tard disent parfois même cinq ou six
mois cette clinique vous en souvenez a
été fermée au début du mois et trois
médecins avaient déjà été écroués cela
fait donc au total six médecins en
prison et c'est ce qui est le plus
inquiétant dans cette affaire c'est que
l'on savait depuis deux ans qu'il se
passait des choses anormales dans cette
clinique
écoutez le témoignage de l'une de nos
concerts je n'ai pas été surprise du
tout parce que il y a deux ans
exactement
j'ai publié dans le monde une enquête
sur l'application générale de la loi en
france et que parmi les médecins que
j'étais allé voir figurer un des deux
inculpés qui m'avait proposé de faire
sur quelqu'un j'avais dû inventer une
soeur imaginaire un avortement à six
mois de grossesse
alors la procédure était la suivante je
ne sais pas s'ils étaient dans la
clinique de la pergola c'était une
clinique privée à l'avortement donc à
six mois avait par césarienne sur une
jeune femme dont j'avais inventé l'âge
en l'occurrence 23 ans et le tarif était
de 8000 francs en 77 et un avortement à
6 mois ne l'avait pas du tout surpris à
mais pas du tout j'ignorais mois qu'on
pouvait opposer demandé à l'avortement
17.5 paraissait inimaginable je voulais
vérifier qu'il en faisait bien six mois
j'ai la vérifier je vais écrit il ya
deux ans dans le monde
par conséquent je pense que depuis au
moins deux ans on aurait pu mener des
enquêtes plus approfondies
que s'est il passé exactement à la
clinique de la pergola
comme dans toutes les affaires les
langues sont longues à se délier j'ai
moi même reçu il ya quelques jours un
appel téléphonique d'un brancardier de
la clinique qui me disait je vais tout
vous raconter ce que j'ai vu là bas
était horrible je n'en dors plus la nuit
et puis plus rien il n'est jamais venu
pourtant le scandale de la pergola ne
date pas d'hier
déjà en 1973 une vingtaine de médecins
d'universitaires de chercheurs réclament
la fermeture de cette clinique où les
accidents entre guillemets se succéder
et la dass direction de l'action
sanitaire et sociale pouvait d'autant
moins ignorer la situation de la pergola
où des avortements à six mois sept mois
de grossesse se faisait à la chaîne son
corps retrouve jamais les nouveau-nés
puisqu'elle avait elle-même
déconventionner à trois reprises
l'établissement et pourtant il a fallu
attendre septembre qu'une sage-femme que
nous avons d'ailleurs interviewé dans le
journal de 20h fasse éclater la faire au
grand jour cette sage-femme disait j'ai
assisté un avortement de sept mois
suivent le bébé sucer son pouce pull a
mystérieusement disparu disparution de
nouveau-nés avortement manque de
personnel et de soin évident il
responsable des cliniques la pergola
vont aujourd'hui en prison vont avoir
répondre à beaucoup de questions et
voyez vous à la veille du débat sur
l'avortement une enquête a été organisé
par des aides de manières de province à
l'initiative de l'association nationale
de la presse catholique
il en ressort que neuf dixièmes des
lecteurs pensent que l'avortement est
bel et bien la suppression d'un être
humain
la plupart estiment également que la
dénatalité est liée à l'extension des
avortements un drame évité dans un cef
des yvelines le cs saint-exupéry à
vélizy près de paris qui accueille 900
élèves à brûler ce matin il n'ya tue
lors il n'y a eu heureusement aucun des
blessés
tous les enfants ont pu être évacués ce
crs avaient subi de très nombreux
aménagements et il semble que la
protection efficace en cas d' incendies
et puis jouer ce matin
la semaine dernière nous vous avions
proposé une enquête sur une université
de province
ouverte aux problèmes régionaux et bien
ce soir nous allons nous rendre dans une
université dont le nom fera tilt dans
vos mémoires nanterre nanterre sortie de
l'anonymat en 68 et qui fut pour
beaucoup le symbole de la contestation
onze ans après vous allez pouvoir en
juger grâce à dominique laurie et
jacques aubertin les choses ont bien
changé
si on regarde ces images qui date de
1970 c'est qu'on retourne aujourd'hui à
l'université de nanterre
on s'aperçoit on se rend compte à quel
point l'université a changé hier un lieu
d'affrontement entre les étudiants
aujourd'hui un lieu de travail car il
est vrai qu'à l'université de nanterre
on travaille aujourd'hui et on y
travaille très sérieusement
c'est bien la même université
mais il est vrai que cette université
qui a fait peur
actuellement est une université qui
attire et elles attirent parce que on
sait qu'elle fait un gros effort
d'ouverture vers l'extérieur et à
l'extérieur
nantes est une ville de 23 mille
étudiants 13 unités d'enseignement et de
recherche les nouvelles filières plus
adapté aux besoins d'aujourd'hui sans
parler de l'institut d'éducation
permanente et les centres de recherche
et les manques moteur les sciences
juridiques qui compte près de 7000 à ce
qu une originalité la double dominante
un enseignement qui devrait permettre
aux étudiants de s'insérer plus
facilement dans la vie professionnelle
une langue du droit viennent appuyer de
la philosophie ou des lettres et à ce
moment-là l'étudiant à une formation qui
est à la fois une formation générale une
formation de réflexion et en même temps
une formation pratique et c'est
l'alliance de ces deux formations qui
permet je crois davantage à l'effusion
de trouver un emploi
l'université devenue sont tout comme les
avec ses difficultés budgétaires
ces problèmes quotidiens et ses
étudiants du 3e âge la cérémonie
écologique la journée de l'arbre à
remplacer les assemblées générales
houleuses et les échanges de balle sur
les courts
les jets de pierres et de boulons
accessoires de la panoplie
contestataires mêlant terre s'est forgé
en dix ans une autre réputation elle se
trouve aujourd'hui dans le peloton de
tête au palmarès des universités
françaises les moins de l'histoire dans
trois seuls les murs ont encore la
parole des murs devant lesquels les
étudiants passent souvent indifférents
je pense que je m'en foutisme en général
peut-être qu'on y pensait - avant
peut-être on attendait moins parler de
l'emploi peut être qu'on avait plus de
motivation à faire de la politique entre
guillemets pour faire de la politique je
crois que les étudiants se défendent
plus par l'accession à leurs diplômes
que par une lutte politique qui fasse je
crois
bien sûr les syndicats sont toujours
présents actifs combatif leurs
revendications sont souvent justifiées
mais la grogne des enseignants face à la
réforme des carrières ou des étudiants
devant les conditions de travail
difficiles ne rencontre que peu d'écho
qu'importe les militants demeure même
s'ils sont peu nombreux
même si la grande majorité des étudiants
ne sont pas organisés dans des
organisations syndicales
ils suivent leurs organisations
syndicales dès qu'il s'agit de leurs
conditions d'études de leur droit aux
études ou de leurs conditions d'études
je crois que tu t'es fait aujourd'hui
pour que les étudiants n'est pas la
parole que les étudiants soient éloignés
des principaux centres de décisions
d'université se trouve effectivement que
très peu d'étudiants participent aux
élections universitaires nous l unef
nous pensons que c'est l'ensemble des
étudiants qui doivent tout faire pour y
participer
reste qu'à peine 5 % des étudiants
participé aux dernières élections
universités devraient faire c'est la fin
d'année le décor est figé pour certains
les fantômes de 68 ont disparu
pour d'autres les grandes idées
également
l'étudiant n'est plus dispo avant tout
il a sa vie ses préoccupations
l'apprentissage d'un mètre et
l'université à nanterre que mayer n'est
plus aujourd'hui qu'un lieu de prades
et pour rester dans le domaine de
l'éducation je vous signale que samedi
et demi sera consacré à l'école des
beaux-arts jean claude mongeau recevra
notamment césar et mathieu d'autres
rendez vous ce soir vers 22h50 le
dernier journal que vous présentera paul
amar et puis d'un 20 heures et après
demain également
léon zitrone avant de vous quitter avant
de passer à la météo je voudrais vous
dire quand n 2 est à l'honneur ce soir
notre chaîne a en effet reçu le
troisième prix du festival international
scientifique de l'émission scientifique
pour le film point 2002 roland martin et
france renucci qui était diffusée dans
fenêtre sur donc la météo il a fait
froid mais beau aujourd'hui sur le
sud-ouest la méditerranée et le bassin
parisien
temps maussade en revanche sur la
bretagne la normandie pour demain du
nord de la loire à l'île de france et
sur la champagne le temps sera nuageux
voire même très nuageux avec des pluies
et de la neige sur les autres régions de
france il fera très froid sec avec tout
de même quand même un petit peu de
soleil
voilà je referme maintenant ce journal
vous souhaite une très bonne fin de
soirée et une très bonne fin de semaine
vous retrouverez avec plaisir lundi pour
soirée
à